hello and welcome to our conference call
MBA admissions insights getting ready to
apply thank you for joining us my name
is Alison Davis I'm associate director
in the MBA admissions office I'm joined
by my colleague Luke Pena director of
MBA admissions hi everyone in the next
thirty minutes we'll be talking about
what to keep in mind as you consider
applying to business school we'll start
by debunking a few common misconceptions
then we'll discuss some questions that
you may find worthwhile to ask yourself
at this stage in the process with some
tips on how to go about answering them
we'll wrap up by answering some of the
questions submitted by you in advance so
let's get started Luke by debunking a
few myths first myth people with my
background don't go to business school
sure I hear this a lot I can debunk this
myth look once upon a time the profiles
of business school in the students do
believe it was very narrow but
management education has evolved a lot
in the last few decades in the last few
years so now you see many business
schools focusing much more broadly on
the idea of developing leadership and so
this means aspiring managers are now
recognizing good leadership this is
needed across all industries and across
all companies not just among the
so-called traditional backgrounds in
fact those of you who with academic and
professional backgrounds where
leadership training is less common
actually may have the most to gain from
an MBA and the most to contribute
absolutely and the potential for
learning and for impact with a
background that might not be so called
traditional it's especially perhaps so
at Stanford we don't have a preference
for or certain academic background or a
certain professional profile we take the
position that diversity of experience
adds immensely and it's integral to your
experience so that means there's not one
right profile there's also not a correct
socio-economic Pro
and I know that's often a great concern
and many of you might worry about the
cost and we work to help offset this
cost with need-based financial aid
programs so I believe that regardless of
your background if you're excited to
learn and grow if you want to help
others learn and grow if you're
passionate about leading organizations
and changing the world in meaningful
ways you should consider a Stanford MBA
here's a common myth I'm too old to
pursue an MBA or I'm too young to pursue
an MBA sure well let me dispel with the
notion of age we don't consider your age
in this process at all we think about
this as career stage and look people at
all different career stages can benefit
from an MBA
now I acknowledge the reasons and the
objectives for pursuing an MBA can
differ a lot based on where you are in
your career and that's great and that's
fine I tend to think it's exciting to be
part of community like Stanford's where
there's a range of objectives and goals
but everybody wants to create meaningful
impact and we sometimes call it an
insane level of greatness and we
acknowledge that everyone defines that
greatness in a different way including
based on where you are in your career so
I tend to think of the MBA as an
investment it's an investment in
yourself and the communities in which
you operate and there's probably never a
wrong time to invest in your own
learning and development that's right
it's never too early in your career to
invest in being a better nor more
self-aware leader on the flip side
you're never too experienced to invest
in your leadership ability so at
Stanford we like having this range of
experiences in the class where you can
learn from others who have different
profiles different levels of experience
so regardless of this experience level
if you recognize the value of this
investment and investing in your
leadership ability again I encourage you
to consider the Stanford MBA another
myth an MBA would narrow my professional
options not broaden them mmm this is a
myth I think mirrors the first myth that
we talked about which was about a narrow
set of pre NBA backgrounds this is the
flip side this is that there are narrow
post MBA paths so let me dispel this
myth remember we talked about management
education evolving it's become
largely industry and company agnostic
and it's focusing its focused on
developing better and more impactful
leaders so at Stanford we focus on
things like general management
curriculum we talk about innovative
thinking we focus on personal leadership
development and global understanding
these are all concepts that are
applicable across across a wide variety
of professional paths so this means you
can apply this toolkit of toolkit of
skills and experience you can apply it
to whatever noble pursuit has meaning
for you when you say that another way
the mba broadens your options is through
the community sure sure that's a great
point you know you have a diverse
community of classmates and alums and
faculty and these individuals are
providing you exposure to a wide variety
of career paths and so many of these
career paths are ones you may not have
encountered before
so at Stanford you're given these
opportunities for exploration and access
to a community that encourages
exploration so my belief is that you
know Stanford MBA actually positions you
for a much broader set professional
options it also imparts you with the
transferable skills that will allow you
to change pads all throughout your
career okay last myth it's best to know
what my post MBA goals are before I go
to business yeah yeah well this builds
on our discussion of the last myth so
you know at MBA at a place like Stanford
we talked about how this broadens
opportunities for professional options
so what this means is that your business
school is actually a great setting and
maybe even the ideal setting to exercise
your curiosity to explore different
career paths and it's ideal here because
you can explore and the downside risk is
low you can use your time here as a
student to do things like pursue an
internship in a completely different
field or shadow a practitioner from
industry or even just schedule things
like coffee chats or lunch talks to
explore and satisfy this curiosity and
students who explore sometimes find
their goals change even as they're
exploring don't they
absolutely you might be surprised to
hear that it's actually 75% of our
students here that switched careers
after the NBA and this is in large part
because of this exposure to classmates
and alums and the faculty and the
visiting speakers that give you these
opportunities to explore and so you may
even have an idea of goals coming in and
that may change and evolve as you
interact with all these different kinds
of people in the community so I will say
if you are somebody that has clear MBA
goals you're very welcome at Stanford
but you are equally welcome if your
reason for pursuing an MBA at Stanford
is to explore and of course will be very
interested in hearing about the ways you
do that thanks Luke next let's talk
about questions that you should be
asking yourself as you're getting ready
to apply in fact answering these
questions for yourself now can probably
save you time later in the application
process so one thing to ask yourself
that's useful is is an MBA the right
degree for me hmmm yeah well let me
start by making an assumption and this
assumption is that if you are listening
right now you are interested in growing
you're interested in improving both on a
professional and a personal level so I
make that assumption so then to answer
this question is the MBA right for me
you have to ask yourself how do you want
to grow but how do you want to improve
and evolve and change and so there are
lots of ways to do this and I will
acknowledge some of the different paths
you know some of you are deciding MBA or
stay in the job a graduate degree or
stay in the job and maybe your current
job gives you opportunities to grow and
develop you know some of you are
deciding which kind of a graduate degree
to pursue their graduate degrees other
professional degrees I acknowledge that
some of you have decided that management
education is right for you but there are
different formats
right there's part-time there's
executive programs there's online
programs and certificate programs and
these all have various pros and cons
even at Stanford we have different
programs like ignite which is a
four-week program sometimes actually a
seven to nine week program for working
professionals both on campus and around
the world
we have a handful of certificates
there's an innovation and
entrepreneurship certificate online
there's a LEED certificate online which
stands for learning gauge accelerate
disrupt we also have an MSX program
right this is a 12 month program for
those of you with at least eight years
of experience so there are so many
different options out there I
acknowledge that will help you grow and
improve and it's so it's worthwhile to
pause and evaluate all of these and see
which one is really the right fit for
growth and improvement for you so
relative to all those other options what
does an MBA offer would you say
yeah well I'm biased of course but I'm
bullish on the MBA and that's for two
reasons the first is the incredible
versatility of this degree as I
mentioned the focus of an MBA here at
Stanford it's not on a narrow specific
career path it's not on a narrowly
defined set of skills it's actually on
broad applicable concepts so innovative
thinking the personal leadership
development self-awareness interpersonal
experiences understanding and navigating
the global landscape around you right
these are all very valuable skills in a
very versatile sense and so this is a
skill set that actually makes you a very
versatile professional so the NVA isn't
just for people pursuing careers in
business hmm no not at all these skills
are applicable all across different
career paths across different cultures
and frankly very appropriate for a world
that's changing rapidly around us so the
diversity of the skill set is broad and
versatile you know the community is also
very broad and so this is a community
that provides perspectives that are much
more varied than you often find in the
workplace or in other graduate degree
programs again people are coming from
all these different backgrounds and that
gives you a learning environment and the
laboratory to expand your perspective
and abilities so that's one reason that
the second reason why I'm bullish on the
MBA it's the idea of the curation of all
of these distinct experiences coming
together so sometimes people ask me why
would I
even bothered with the NBA and that's a
fair question so in my opinion I believe
it's impossible to curate all by
yourself all of the experiences that an
NBA simultaneously offers well can you
can you replicate the classroom learning
with the faculty that we have here right
can you replicate the emphasis on
innovation the immersive opportunities
to practice leadership the global
experiences you can you can you curate
this all on your own
can you assemble 400 plus people who are
some of the most amazing and inspiring
and ambitious future leaders to make
that your own support network if you can
do all this on your own then maybe you
don't need the MBA but if you recognize
the value and immersing yourself an
environment where all of this comes
together then I encourage you take a
good long look at a Stanford MBA now I
should mention one other thing some of
you are interested in management
education and a business degree you're
also interested in studying something
else simultaneously and this is a really
exciting and growing area and business
and MBA schools it's the idea of doing a
joint dual degree and so many schools
Stanford among them offer the
opportunity to study business and
something else and so if that applies to
you you can pursue that will actually
talk more about joint and dual degrees
and another one of these discussions
coming in the next few months thanks Lou
another question when is the right time
for me to go back to school mm-hmm well
let me address an important distinction
here so there are different times to
apply to school if let's say you're
applying to Stanford as a college senior
or as a current graduate student who has
continued straight through from
undergrad you have the option of
applying for admission and if you're
admitted deferring your admission to a
future year so similarly if you're
already working but you are interested
in applying to a joint or dual degree
you may also defer your admission to
pursue that other degree first so those
of you that fall into those groups have
some flexibility about when you start
now if you're already working and you're
not applying for a joint or a dual
degree we do expect you to apply in the
year when you plan to enroll so for
those of you who are in this
this is a very important and a very
timely question to ask and the short and
simple answer is when you're ready you
go back to school when you're ready and
you know remember our dispelling of the
myth earlier that you know you can have
too little experience or too much
experience that's not true this frees
you up to apply at that point in your
career when you are truly ready so the
obvious question is how would you know
if you're ready oh sure well I believe
the right time is when you are ready for
change when you're ready for some sort
of change
now that is defined in different ways
for each of you
right for some of you that might be
changing the very work that you do you
want to change industries you want to
change you know the very nature of the
work that you're doing others of you may
like the industry you're in or the
company you work for but you want to
change your approach and how you think
about the work that you're doing so
there are different ways to define this
but I believe that the time to know when
you're ready it's when you recognize
this opportunity to advance your
passions to advance your interests by
making this investment in yourself and
the impact you have in your communities
this is there a cost though to
interrupting your career mm-hmm yeah
sure in fact I think of two costs the
first cost is a financial cost right now
Business School is not only an
investment in yourself and your skills
it's also a literal financial investment
and I acknowledge you spend money to
come to school but I also hope that you
don't consider that a deterrent and so
we're fortunate at Stanford to have a
very generous need-based financial aid
program this helps fund students based
on your financial need to attend so we
strive to eliminate that as a barrier
for study
now the second cost is opportunity cost
stepping away from your career and so
for a full-time MBA like Stanford that's
stepping away for two years perhaps even
longer if you're pursuing one of the
joining dual degree programs and so
there are professional considerations
there are personal considerations you
know are you moving a family are you
delaying some some other goal that's
involved in your personal life to come
and study a Business School I
acknowledge all of these things
so when you think about this cost I want
to return to the framework of business
school it has an investment it's an
investment in yourself it's an
investment in your future and it's an
investment in the communities and the
impact that you'll have within them so
as those of you who have experience with
investing know with any investment
there's not for a cost and as with any
worthwhile investment there are also
rewards that justify that cost and so
you know there were words here you know
from an MBA and from a Stanford MBA they
may be financial but I actually believe
the more valuable rewards manifest
themselves in the form of a career of
impact a life of meaning so I say you
know think not just about the short-term
cost think about the long-term rewards
that pay dividends for the rest of your
life and so you know when you're ready
regardless of your career stage when
you're ready to make this investment
that does have the short-term cost but
pays the long-term dividends and impact
and meaning that's what you know what's
the right time third question is this
the right school for me hmm there are so
many schools around the world so and so
many of them offering management
education and sometimes this can feel
like a curse because there's an
abundance of option but I actually
encourage you think of it as a blessing
because each school is different and
that means each one has a different
value proposition no there's a myth that
we didn't dispel earlier but I wanted to
spell now that myth is that there is
some Universal ranked order of schools
and that a higher ranked school is
inherently better than a lower ranked
school for all of you that that's simply
not true each one of you listening has a
different set of schools that are best
for you and this is based on a widely
varying set of personal criteria so in
this sense do the research on the
schools and do that research not based
on some list or what somebody else says
is right apply your criteria that's
important you know so for some of you
you'll care about location and some of
you will care about the culture of the
school some of you will care about how
are you taught in the class what are the
teaching methods and some of you care
about is it a general management program
are there concentrations and majors that
allow you to very deeply specialize so
pay attention to the criteria but pay
attention in regards to your specific
set of interests and desires
what would you say differentiates
Stanford hmm well I think of this in in
three frames and three elements and
they're progressively deeper so the
first element is programmatic features
okay so these are things like location
right so we're in California and this is
a place where there's enthusiasm about
innovation and exploring the unknown and
I think about the structure of the
program so ours is a general management
curriculum so we focus on broad
applicable skills that are transferable
across industries right we focus on
things like experiential leadership
rather than strictly theoretical
instruction in fact the classroom
instruction it's a combination of both
research faculty and practitioners so
these are the programmatic elements if
you go a level deeper you look at the
people in a community so at Stanford we
have a small class it's just over 400 in
each class and the students get to know
each other not just as classmates but as
friends and as people that they can
count on to support one another right
it's a feedback it's a feedback
dominated culture so we encourage
students to practice giving each other
feedback and to develop each other's
leadership through this through this
practice the alumni community as a
result of the small tight-knit community
it's very strong
it's very responsive but then you go
even one level deeper right and you
arrive at the values and so the values
of a place like Stanford focus on
personal transformation they focus on
self awareness and ultimately focus on
values based decision making and making
decisions based on what has meaning and
impact for you so this to me suggests a
really powerful insight about the values
at Stanford when you come here and you
graduate we hope that your pursuit and
your goal is not success okay success is
fine it's a good thing it's it's fine to
want but but we hope that's not the
primary goal because it's superficial
it's temporary and times completely out
of our control
so you know this is your goal your may
or may not find it so instead we
encourage you to position
to transform I don't think of the goal
as happiness and meaning right and
purpose and so these are noble pursuits
that you can in fact attain and achieve
so if this is your pursuit
chances are go find it and chances are
you're more likely to find success as a
by-product it sounds all pretty
aspirational what tactical steps can our
listeners take to determine if Stanford
or another school is right for them sure
two suggestions
the first engage with us we've got lots
of opportunities to engage with the
Stanford community as well as other
business school communities so if you're
so inclined come and see us on campus if
you can't visit campus attend one of the
events around the world that we put on
check us out online we have more of
these online events coming we've got
some great videos online look at student
profiles so we put out a lot of content
for you to understand the school now
this is a lot of data and information
from the school but it can be one
directional so you also have to self
assess you have to take action in
response to learning about the school
and self assess to make sure the
community is aligned with your own
values and I think one simple trick for
this is you know look at what the school
is asking you for example in the
application essays sketch out you know
some light responses and see what
reaction you have you know if you get
excited about that
that tells you one thing and if you have
a different reaction that may tell you
another thing about your fit with the
school great look let's move on now to
answering audience questions thanks to
so many of you who submitted questions
in advance okay what are some things we
can do three to six months prior to
submitting an application to a full-time
MBA program three to six months this is
this is a great time for reflections
right I think sometimes the temptation
is to think of the application it's just
a series of checkboxes and and steps
that you have to go through to be a
candidate but actually reflection goes a
long way towards helping you know if
this is truly the right path for you so
once you've decided that this is the
right path plan you know step put
together a plan look at the deadlines
for when you
to apply and work backwards from that
deadline so that you prepare and give
yourself enough time I also encourage
you to identify the resources that will
help you best prepare and so resources
look like they manifest in a lot of
different ways but I think maybe the
most important is get the people around
you who will be your support network who
can give you feedback on your
application and who can give you
guidance on preparing for this big step
and then finally as I mentioned check in
with yourself along the way you know
self assess how are you feeling how are
you responding as you're moving through
this process you're excited or you're
not or you're dreading it this is
valuable feedback for yourself
that you should take into consideration
this next question is about application
rounds I've heard that admissions rates
differ between different application
rounds how should this factor into our
decision about which round to apply for
well you should apply when you're ready
and when your application is complete
now I think it's important to note we do
not enter a round with a quota for
admission offers we don't go into a
round with a fixed admission rate in
mind know that the number of admission
offers and arounds depends on the number
of qualified candidates relative to the
pool and that changes from one round to
the next from one year to the next and
it's not something we predict so apply
when you're ready I do think it's wise
to apply as early as your application is
complete round three has historically
been a very competitive round for us and
in the last few years we've received
more applications in round two and
that's made that round more competitive
so on the margin I would say applies as
early as you can but the most important
factor is that you should feel your
application is complete and you were
ready to submit Luke what advice do you
have for more traditional applicants who
already have some exposure to the mba
application process what should they
focus on in their preparation the focus
should be on yourself and what do I mean
by that you want to really truly examine
why this path this MBA this timing in
the school is right for you and I think
this is especially critical for those of
you where there are many candidates
flying from your company or from your
industry because there's this temptation
to fall into groupthink right everybody
else is applying to this school or
applying at this time in their career so
you should - no let me challenge that
but you want to resist that temptation I
think you also have to work to resist
the temptation to try to differentiate
yourself and again you you know you see
yourself wanting to position yourself
and compare yourself to the others that
you know who are applying I say let go
of that it's hard but let go of that
those who try hardest to stand out in
this process are usually the ones who
end up standing out the least so instead
of trying to be different just be
yourself right that's the best way to be
a great candidate and let that self that
sense of self and identity really emerge
here's a question from an international
student who asks if I have already
visited the campus and attended a class
what are some of the other opportunities
I should be looking out for which will
help me understand the Stanford culture
better hmm I like that idea of culture
you know culture is such a significant
part of the business school experience
it's certainly a differentiating factor
among business schools and so this is an
important thing to pay attention to now
culture isn't manufactured in the
abstract by a school well it's it forms
and emerges from the people who are part
of that community
so to really understand the culture you
have to understand the people and what
do they value what drives them what
gives them passion and meaning and so
this actually allows me to to lump in
another question that we received and
that question is you know is there a way
to connect with Stanford GSB students or
alumni as we prepared to apply and this
is the spirit of wanting to get to know
that culture absolutely you know we want
you to know our community to know our
students and alums and so we have a lot
of ways that you can do this right if
you have if you do visit campus we have
students here who speak at our sessions
especially when school is in session and
we have class visits but even if you've
already visited campus or you can't
visit campus we're going out in the next
few months all over the world and
hosting events in the large metropolitan
areas of the world we feature alumni and
students at those events and so it's a
way to directly engage
we have a lot of great information on
the web there are social media profiles
of students we have a week in the life
series where students highlight what a
week in their life looks like we've got
some great new videos on our YouTube
channel where students talk about what
the experience is like at the school and
so you've got faculty videos visiting
speaker videos so there's some great
content online where you can understand
the culture there's also these events
where you can interact with students and
alums directly does admission see and
care if an applicant has visited campus
we're delighted to have you visit campus
we're delighted to offer these
opportunities you know we have
information sessions Monday and Friday
all throughout the year we have class
visits during 3/4 the the fall the
winter in the spring when classes are in
session
we even have larger visit programs these
are coming this September so things like
many voices for diverse perspectives we
have an X X Factor event for women who
want to change the world we've got a
visit day which is a general visit event
and these are day-long events now we
have these opportunities but I want to
be very clear we offer these to help you
understand the Stanford experience and
culture and many applicants find this to
be a helpful step in preparation but we
do not weigh them in our evaluation
process it's very important to preserve
fairness and equity and we understand
that some of you have the opportunity of
the visit some of you do not and so it's
not an advantage or a disadvantage in
the evaluation process it's for your
research we're almost out of time if you
didn't get your question answered today
feel free to contact our office by email
or phone to ask your question Luke
before we go any words of advice for our
listeners today yeah I've been careful
not to talk too much about the
application itself it is important to us
but we wanted to focus today first on
how to get ready to apply and we will
talk about the application and future
discussions in this series now that
being said our first essay question is a
question that I believe is worth
considering not just when completing the
application but also when you're
deciding why to apply when to apply
where to apply and that first question
is what matters no
to you and why okay so we believe that
the purpose of a Stanford MBA is to
position you to change lives to change
organizations to change the world but in
order to do that you have to first
examine how you might change and you
might grow and you might evolve and in
order to do that you have to know and
understand yourself so before you pick a
degree right before you pick the year or
around to apply before you pick the
schools to apply to you owe it to
yourself to really truly examine who you
are examine what matters to you and
examine what about your answer drives
and motivates you to take this step in
your career in your life if you do that
work of self-examination upfront you
will be a better applicant you'll be a
happier student and you'll be a more
impactful alone
great advice Luke thank you and thank
you all for joining us there are three
more MBA admissions insight conference
calls coming up including preparing for
your letters of reference and essays on
July 12 being a great applicant on
August 10th and considering a joint or
dual degree on August 31st you can sign
up for these on our website an audio
recording of each of these conference
calls including the one today will be
posted on our website in the next few
weeks the current application is now
available on our website there are three
application deadlines September 21
January 10 and April 5 as Luke said
earlier there are lots of ways to learn
more about our program and the admission
process on our website you'll find
videos of webinars and a calendar of
events offered both on campus and around
the world we look forward to meeting you
online or in person goodbye for now